you might not spend much time thinking
about making yourself less attractive if
any except when it comes to mosquitoes
summer means they'll be out in force
once again but turns out there are
things you can do to keep them out of
your backyard and off your skin Nikki
Batiste has the story
mosquitoes they're pesky and persistent
I go outside mosquito already bit me and
they're attracted to humans likely
because the females need blood to
reproduce they're very sophisticated
little little bugs Catherine Roberts is
a health and science editor for Consumer
Reports what attracts mosquitoes to us
it really can depend on what you're
wearing your skin different people are
more attractive than others a recent
preliminary study by Virginia Tech found
that certain soaps with a floral or
fruity scent made people even more
attractive to mosquitoes and on average
more than 60 percent of what a mosquito
smells after you wash comes from soap
rather than Natural Body odors what can
we do to keep mosquitoes away use an
effective insect repellent we found in
our tests repellents that have about 25
to 30 percent DEET tend to be the most
reliable so if you're looking for
Alternatives one is called picaridin the
other is oil of Lemon Eucalyptus so
citronella candles are not very
effective Instead try using a fan
mosquitoes aren't very good Flyers
eliminate standing water which attracts
them and wear long pants and sleeves
that are loose fitting the more it rains
the more mosquitoes you find around and
climate change may be why you're feeling
more bites this summer climate change is
not only going to increase the number of
mosquitoes that are around but it's also
going to increase the number of places
where mosquitoes can leave if you do get
bitten the CDC advises washing the area
applying an ice pack and using an
antihistamine cream to reduce any
itching for CBS Saturday morning Nikki
Batiste New York
for people who get bit a lot that's my
mom I'm talking to you anything they'll
do anything to get less bites I'm a
magnet for them yeah see right anything
yeah they've been around for a billion
years they'll be around one billion more
it certainly will kill more people than
any other disease or person known to man
so
think about that